two weeks ago I announced a deck
building challenge and that challenge
went as follows choose a commander from
among a marshall of Rohan yomiji H bars
the way Egon god of death shizuko caller
of Autumn and SRA peacock and build a
deck with it prioritizing creativity
cohesion and likelihood to produce
Dynamic gameplay over the course of the
ensuing week an explosion of deck
building occurred far more than I
expected honestly and at the end of this
period I was left with around 250 decks
to dig through I went through every
single one of these decks reading
primers and scoping out card choices and
feeling out The Vibes until I was left
with a handful of finalists for each of
the commanders I then discussed these
finalists with a couple friends who help
me pick out a winner for each of the
five so I will now be announcing those
winners talking about each of those
decks and also giving some honorable
mentions which will be shown off in the
r tab on my website I'll also give some
ideas for improvement where I see fit
these are all great decks and many are
creative in ways I probably wouldn't
think to be but the task of improving an
already great deck is a fun one and I
love having fun let's start with Senator
peacock a five band commander who makes
all your artifacts Clues artifacts which
can be sacrificed to draw a card and who
makes a creature unblockable whenever
you sacrifice a clue most decks
submitted for this fell into one of two
categories artifact good stuff decks and
political Decks that played off the
Commander's Senator status for a few
honorable mentions we had an artifact
based combo deck a ninjas deck and a
stack deck all of which can be found in
a link in the description however for
this Commander there was a clear winner
among both me and the people I discussed
things with filthy Stacks players
modular Beatdown deck see one of the
difficulties with Senator peacock and a
reason she likely had so few decks as of
the start of this challenge was that for
each of her two abilities there are
commanders that do something similar at
a better rate this makes her hard to
justifies a commander choice if you're
primarily only using one of her two
modes so a clear goal for building a
cator peacock deck is figuring out how
to use both halves of the card the
sacrifice to draw as well as the evasion
modular is a brilliant solution to this
challenging question artifact creatures
that transfer their plus one plus1
counters to other creatures when they
die have both a clear reason to want to
hit the yard and a clear reason to want
to be unblockable
now all of this comes at a cost and
that's that there aren't very many
modular creatures and a lot of the ones
that do exist are terrible this deck
runs all the ones within its color
identity that cost four or less Mana
which ends up being a total of nine some
of these are still pretty bad such as
arcbound hybrid a 2 two haste creature
for four Mana but the keyword is what
really matters and the rest of the deck
is built out to bolster that keyword the
deck is running a number of other cards
that can grant and gain counters as well
as nine proliferate cards and eight
other cards that can utilize counters in
some way these include things like Danny
pink that provide payoffs for counters
moving around as well as cards like
giggling skitter Spike and ink moth
Nexus that provide excellent
destinations for counters to be placed
on I like that this deck doesn't overuse
infect it's common for players to throw
some extra infect into a proliferate
deck as an alternate wicon which works
but can really put opponents on edge and
attract unwanted attention here the
infect cards are kept exclusively to Ink
moth Nexus as a potential one shot with
modular and plag Meir as a card that
doubles as a dork and this definitely is
a healthy place to stop overall this
deck's Beatdown game plan seems quite
decent and even features tangle Trove
kelp as a top end card that goes
unbelievably hard with peacock to
bolster its artifact beats this deck
also features a lovely Suite of support
cards it's packing plenty of interaction
with seven cards aimed at countering
spells or protecting things and nine
cards aimed primarily at removal or
defense and there are a handful of cards
in other categories that can also serve
removing purposes such as contagion
engine there's also a quite nice layer
draw and ramp Suite 10 cards each that
i' categorize is primarily in one of
those categories but also a lovely range
of cards that serve double duty with
other purposes tzr Gambit draws and
proliferates staff of completion ramps
and proliferates cryptic troby ramps and
holds counters defir betrayer of Flesh
draws and ramps and season of weaving
does all sorts of stuff this overlapping
of roles along with the deck's
relatively low Mana curve likely lets it
play quite smoothly so overall I'm a big
fan of this deck it uses the commander
excellently and features a well-chosen
and well-rounded Suite of cards within
it it looks capable of putting on
pressure in multiple different ways
dishing out good damage but also being
resilient and able to play into a longer
and grinder game to get to some points
of improvement I personally would try to
build out more of a recursion Suite
scrap trer mirr retriever even something
like inventive iteration all of these
provide nice ways to bring back some of
the lower cost sacrifice modular
creatures and utilize them further which
could allow the deck to maintain
pressure better moving along the next
Commander is suzuko color of autum a
three Mana 23 that produces three green
Mana for each player on their untap step
that sticks around for the whole turn
this one is definitely the most
open-ended out of the bunch and is also
a pretty group Huggy card in general
most of the shizuko submissions involved
some blend of battle cruiser group hug
and stacks roughly in that order of
popularity however there were also some
very different submissions as well
honorable mentions for this category
included a storm deck a face down
creatures Deck with the goal of not
tapping lands on its own turn and a
protean Hulk combo deck sped up by
shizuko's Mana boost you can check out
all of those in the link in the
description the winner of shizuko was
once again relatively clear to my team
spell Tex land deck this is a deck with
the goal of repeatedly looping Talon
Gates of bandara in order to keep
shizuko phased out on opposing untap
steps preventing them from Gaining her
Mana this is a great concept I wouldn't
have ever thought to try and fully break
parody on shizuko's ability I definitely
asked myself the question of whether
it's worth the effort and from a
strategic optimization sort of
standpoint that's a valid question but I
think there's enough there to work with
a one-sided three Mana boost on a three
Mana Commander is nothing to sneeze at
and worth putting a bit of effort into
maintaining and keeping shizuko phased
out also has some side benefits like
strengthening the deck's boardwipe
resistance it's also if nothing else
very funny to play a group hug Commander
only to put a lot of effort into denying
opponents the hug as you might expect
this deck runs all the cards needed to
enable the shizuko phase out plan tutors
to find the Talon Gates CS to sacrifice
lands to perform effects and cards that
allow the deck to access Lance from its
graveyard all of these are already great
things for a lance deck to have so the
fact that they're all that's required to
enable this deck's devious hug denial is
a big point in its favor as with most
land decks this is a deck that we'll be
looking to acqu acquire different lands
for different situations Cavern of souls
helps get around counter spells Basia
who endures can deal with artifacts and
enchantments glacial Chasm ston walls
aggression scavenger grounds deals with
graveyards and so on these lands make up
this deex toolbox it's base of cards
that it can draw on through tutors to
help remedy various problems that it
might encounter in addition a good
portion of these lands have effects that
involve sacrificing or discarding them
and then this allows these effects to be
utilized multiple times six or life from
The Lone can repeat cycle lands or Buu
and all manner of sacrifice land can be
repeated through undergrowth Recon
raming up excavator or ainus
gloomstalker this allows the deck to be
quite grindy usually having something it
can put his Mana into the deck also has
lots of other neat utility cards woven
throughout it a number of different
options for Stacks defense and removal
can be found throughout the deck many of
them concentrated among the lands though
the deck doesn't have a ton of options
for each different type of effect its
toolbox in nature and high density of
recursion likely means it should be able
to repeat various interactive effects as
necessary finally this deck has a few
different options for winning the first
is a classic thespian stage can become a
copy of dark depths original depths is
sacrificed to the legend rule the former
stage is sacrificed to create a 2020
Merit lodge because it has no counters
on it rinse and repeat with land
recursion if the Merit Lodge dies the
deck can also go wide with field of the
dead or Titania protector of argoth and
Helix Pinnacle serves as a l Resort Mana
sync windc con if the board is forfeit
and the deck is buckling down behind a
glacial Chasm or a constant Mists the
next looping nature also means that
there are some incidental infinite
combos if it gets enough mana and pieces
but these feel more more than fair
they're more a byproduct of being ahe
rather than setting up for a combo in
the traditional sense so overall the de
seems well-rounded and fun if I were to
offer a point of critique I'd say that
this deck could use some more options
for extra land play being able to Loop a
utility land two or three times a turn
rather than one is a big deal and could
allow the deck to spend its shizuko Mana
more effectively my friend 33 elk who's
a lands official n also suggested n as
intervention as a good card as well as a
card like yava cradle of growth that
could allow glacial Chasm and dark
depths to tap for Mana just a handful
ideas for land players out there the
third Commander for among the five was
aomr Marshall of Rohan a four Mana 44
haste creature that grants an extra
combat once per turn when another
attacking legendary creature dies this
was actually the card that inspired the
challenge here was a commander with a
wonderfully textured ability on it and
yet it only had around 100 decks on Eda
Tre there were a lot of super cool
versions of this Commander submitted a
few honorable mentions were a goblin
deck that paired aers ability with a
variety of different goblins a toolbox
combo deck that focused on staying
flexible while keeping opponents on
their toes and a hyper budget pingers
Deck with no sacrifice Outlets all three
of these can be found at the link in the
description for the number one deck
though we have lock fins reanimator deck
yes that's monor red reanimator this
deck focused around a specific critical
card God Pharaoh's gift this is a seven
Mana artifact that reads at the
beginning of combat on your turn you may
Exile a creature card from your
graveyard if you do create a token
that's a copy of that card except it's a
four4 black zombie it gains haste until
end of turn extra combats from aomr mean
extra zombies from God gift allowing the
deck to build Advantage as successive
combat phases pass naturally there are a
number of different components that the
deck needs in order to accomplish its
God Pharaoh gifting the first of these
is tutors of which the deck is running
four one of these is gate to the at life
a card that searches up God Pharaoh's
gift by name so that's pretty cool the
other three tutors are gamble style
effects where cards are searched up
followed by a discard at random and
these are nice because even if the
tutored card gets discarded the deck has
plenty of ways of reanimating artifacts
speaking of the deck runs four cards
that return artifacts from his graveyard
to play including a new d That's being
printed in the upcoming bracing themed
set three out of the four of these cards
require artifacts to sacrifice so the
deck also contains five cards that
generate artifact tokens and that's in
addition to the fact that about a
quarter of the deck is artifacts that
themselves can be sacrificed the final
thing required for this deck's
reanimated plan is ways to get cards
into the graveyard and it has a wide
variety of these there are several
filtering cards like faithless looting
and brasses tunnel grinder that help the
deck selectively TOS stuff into the yard
as well as a handful of M effects like
milikin or alter of dementia this list
of different things prior for the
artifact reanimation plan may sound like
a major hurdle to the deck's
functionality but thankfully all of
these different tools are helpful on
their own and most serve other purposes
for the deck which is good because all
of that was just to get godf faroh's
gift on board and fueled up in the first
place from here we need to gain some
extra combats in order to take advantage
of the card to do this we really only
need three things a on board legendary
creatures to die while attacking and
effects to ensure their death there are
some number of Fairly conventional sack
Outlets but also some fling effects and
some cards that can copy legendary
creatures one of these is blade of s a
card that goes infinish with aomr by
creating two copies of him when he
attacks that immediately see each other
die to Legend rule giving two additional
combats and this then continues until
there are fewer than four players in the
game a number of submitted aomar decks
included this card but the fact that
this deck gets additional value on each
combat phase gives it a much better
chance of being able to win the game
right then and there rather than just
deleting the opponent who forgot to pack
blockers and then passing the turn and
this sort of thing would be very much an
earned combo win in my book if you do
the setup of getting your core engine
online getting a stock graveyard for it
getting blade of s and obtaining a clear
attack path for aomr it's hard to call
that gimmicky or unearned overall this
deck is doing a lot of good stuff and
has some cool cohesion to it as far as
areas of improvement go the removal
Suite is relatively sparse consisting of
mostly a handful of fling effects plus a
portal to forexia while this could work
for a more aggressive deck godf faroh's
gift is very much a value overtime sort
of card and some more tools to slow down
opponents to help the deck gain that
time would likely be welcome the fourth
Commander is god of death this one is
dual-sided the front side is a three
Mana 66 death touch that is sacrificed
on upkeep unless its controller Exiles
two cards from their graveyard the
backside is a one Mana artifact that
Mills a card from its controller's
Library each turn and has a three Mana
tap ability that Exiles a creature card
from its controller's graveyard and
draws a card around half of submissions
were basically a generic is throne of
death graveyard pile if some form or
other but among the other half of decks
there was a ton of variety exiting
graveyard synergies things to take
advantage of Egon sweet power to Mana
cost ratio some funky control decks with
Throne of death and and so on one of the
trickiest things about picking a
favorite deck for this Commander was
asking the question of what decks
represented aegon a deck can have aegon
or Throne of death in the command Zone
but one of my main judging criteria was
cohesion and to me cohesion requires
that a deck feels like the commander
truly belongs there were some really
cool honorable mentions for this one
including two different secret Commander
decks one with hack on and nazguls that
was all about playing kns from the
graveyard and one with convergence of
dominion that was all about using
creatures with graveyard abilities
however the deck that felt the most
undenied Aon of the bunch was starf fiz
Voltron deck now I did get a handful of
other Voltron submissions but this deck
was A Cut Above the Rest in one key area
compactness I discussed compactness in
my last video as a necessary feature in
a deck that is going to need to devote
some unnegotiable amount of space to a
particular task in this case one of the
biggest challenges of building an aegon
Voltron deck is navigating his downside
while still building a functional deck
for Voltron purposes aegon has a pretty
clear upside he's a 66 death touch
beater for three Mana a pretty
unbeatable raid however the need to
constantly restock the graveyard to keep
Exile f for him poses a real challenge
if we think about Mill as its own
category of card and think about how
many sources of Mill are needed in order
to constantly keep eggon up it's kind of
a lot like 15 is my go-to number for a
card I want during the vast majority of
curve outs and I'll even hedge closer to
20 if it's a card type I truly can't
live without that's not an insignificant
amount of deck space where starf his
deck stands out then is in his
proficiency at integrating this
essential task into the the rest of his
game plan making the task of keeping a
graveyard stocked for Egon to eat a
mostly painless one there are around
seven or eight cards i' identify as
being basically exclusively graveyard
fodder which isn't a horrendously High
number and then the rest of the deck's
graveyard stalking is built into other
categories you've got fantastic draw
engines like ripples of undeath and mask
of memory you've got armix in the
removal sphere a bunch of other assorted
cards with discard or Mill attached and
that's not even getting to the lands the
deck is running a big old pile of fetch
lands as well as several other adjacent
effects like Travelers Amulet the net
result of this is that the deck has a
decent handful of High Caliber Mill
engines but also a ton of cards that
incrementally contribute to the sell
Mill game plan Without Really requiring
any commitment what does the rest of
this deck look like well among the core
Voltron pieces you've got six protection
pieces four pieces of evasion and 11
cards for puming up aegon's power the
protection was roughly what you'd expect
all the classics like Swift foot boots
as well as assault suit which is a fun
inclusion as both extra damage and as
anti-s sacrifice Tech among the evasion
cards three of the four Grant trample
which makes sense with a death touch
Commander you don't really need
conventional evasion if you have a death
touch Commander that's too big for
opponents to kill we also see five haste
enablers which makes sense with a
commander with a very efficient power to
cost ratio the pump cards are
interesting both in terms of what's here
and in the fact that the deck has so
many a lot of the Voltron builds I saw
for Egon largely neglected the bigger
pump equipments basically accepting that
they were going to be finishing off
opponents in three to four hits this is
a valid choice but it does remove a lot
of the explosive bite of one to two hit
kill Voltron the player removal is less
of an option when those players have
longer to do their problematic game
plans among the rest of this deck we
have a decently Hefty removal Suite A
Modest ramp package an average siiz draw
package and a small handful of leaving
graveyard synergies overall this stick
seems quite well-rounded and placed to
the strengths of Egon if I had to offer
points of improvement my only note would
be that fitting in a bit more evasion
might be wise since four is a number
that you might struggle to find some
games the final commander option was
yomiji who bars the way this is a seven
Mana 44 that reads whenever another
legendary permanent is put into a
graveyard return that card to its
owner's hand I wanted to have different
commanders that would appeal to
different sorts of players in this
Challenge and this one is definitely
aimed at the most audacious Johnnies of
the world the first thing that jumps out
when looking at the card is that
glorious original Kagawa Jank Factor
this card is a seven Mana 44 with no
keywords and a single line of text that
is basically a symmetrical status effect
this card is on the surface bad but it's
also undeniably unique there is no other
Commander that comes anywhere close to
doing what this card does I made a
discussion for him with a thread for
discussing each of the five commanders
and the yumii thread saw more activity
than the other four combined these folks
were cooking there were all sorts of
decks submitted control decks Spirit
decks blink decks Super Friends decks
combo decks of all stripes and more this
Commander also saw a difficult decision
among the top two decks heighten $50
control deck was an undeniably cool
budget Riff on the commander complete
with all sorts of creative packages for
grinding value however it was the sheer
cohesion tuning and Clarity of vision in
Alf Zero's high power combo deck that
ended up coming out on top the basic
shape of most of the deck's combos goes
something like this you've got your
legendary permanent to be looped your
sacrifice outlet and then some sort of
payoff take MOX Amber you cast it you
tap it for Mana you sacrifice it to give
thermal Navigator flying yiji bars the
way and sends it back to your hand and
then you rinse and repeat as necessary
that then with the arbitrary amount of
white Mana that results you can Loop a
different artifact such as thron ofel
drain repeatedly casting and activating
the draw two cards ability until you
find something like grinding station or
blind obedience which can turn further
looping into an endless stream of Mill
or life loss respectively for your
opponents there are a number of
different ways to assemble a combo here
one piece of this is that there are six
sack Outlets which each combo with
different selections of loopable
legendaries and payoffs the iron crack
is an infinite colorless Mana generator
if C Clan Iron Works and the commander
are out but a simple Mana rock with any
other sack Outlet hope of gapur is an
infinite Mana generator with ashnod
alter and C Clan Ironworks on board
infinitely castable but needing an
outlet with a forian alter on board and
a simple one- one flyer with any of the
other three sack Outlets the fact that
it's both a creature and an artifact
makes hope of Geer one of the most
important legendaries in the deck for
looping purposes alongside MOX opal and
MOX Amber which generate infinite
colored Mana with any of the deck's four
artifact sack Outlets Omar this is an
honorable mention here a card that can
be cast an arbitrary number of times for
x equals 0
how does the deck translate any of these
things into winds well for starters
simply looping a creature such as om
arthus or hope of Geer can go infinite
with either glaring flesh raker or
orchetra monument dealing either
infinite damage to opponents or creating
an infinite number of one- one Soldiers
the deck also has a number of outlets to
pump infinite Mana into five of these
draw cards in order to find a way to win
the game and the last of these is blind
obedience which can be used to drain out
opponents the drawing Outlets would
likely be used to find either blind
obedience grinding station or glaring
flesh raker the three of which
constitute the deck's most definite
wions this deck is neat because of the
sheer number of different ways it can
put together a combo a number that is
Amplified by three cost reducers that
can turn the most unlikely options into
combo pieces to facilitate this combo
most of the rest of the deck is geared
toward draw tutors and especially ramp
the deck features 23 cards that ramp in
some form or other along with 10 tutors
and eight draw spells these are good
numbers given that the deck has a seven
Mana commander and a multi-piece combo
to put together the deck is doing pretty
well for interaction as well the deck
features seven pieces of removal and 10
pieces of protection and this focus on
protection makes sense given the deck
status as a pure combo deck the deck's
structure also itself makes the deck
resilient to hate as there are so many
different ways to piece together combos
that no singular piece is loadbearing
and most pieces involved in a combo can
also serve other purposes for the deck
overall this deck has all the Hallmarks
I would look for in a healthy combo deck
has plenty of interaction points but is
resiliant to setbacks it is firmly
pursuing its combo as a game plan
complete with the tutors and protection
spells needed to consistently do such a
thing but it also has removal to slow
opponents love to see it all right
that's the decks I was quite happy with
the results of this challenge I saw a
lot more enthusiasm in my Discord server
for this challenge than I had expected
and it led to a whole bunch of really
cool decks getting built for some under
appreciated commanders I'll probably do
something like this again in the future
and you can leave comments with
inspiration for what that should look
like with that said thanks for watching
and thanks to architect for supporting
the channel going through hundreds of
decks I really appreciated the ones on
architect for one simple reason the
scryfall style search bar if I want to
see a deck's enchantments with the word
sacrifice in the text I could just type
that search into the search bar and be
there in 2 seconds if I want to see all
the equipment in a deck that Grant haste
search bar that aside shout out to my
patrons for their continued support of
what I do here I just opened up
submissions for my November Deck review
so if you want a chance at having me do
an in-depth review of your deck you can
join my patreon and submit a deck within
the next week I recently set all of my
deck reviews to public so if you want to
see more of what those look like before
paying me that's an option if you want
to see more from me out side of that you
can check out the podcast I'm a part of
over on the trinket mes Channel all
right bye